let the mvp race
you don't blow me this thing honestly
drives itself yo pull up forever i'm
here for the watch
party margin receivers can't win anyway
straight up just cliff guardrail mike
you gotta cut me out of the narrative
position players will never win mvp
let's go quarterback we support you get
in jt hey carson want me to drive for
you like normal
take the blue ball and continue living
in the qb friendly league but take the
red ball oh dang you took them both so
many carries he is the one
[Music]
see nine years ago the cubies rose up
and assured that only they would win
these people are trapped in delusions
not gonna lie i'm barely following
never send a man to do a machine's job
whoa they recast agent brady that's so
weird
they took henry out i used to be like
them but then they made me an mvp
candidate and i knew it was all fake
that's it i know the secret no one is
really playing well this year so the
first half of the season just like
doesn't matter yeah you can always just
come back people love sequels any
weapons i am a weapon
take me higher than i've ever been
boom
yo what's up fam we took it to slow mo
yet again to show you oh jt knows he's
in slow girl i see the holes in the
matrix now of course they would never
let me win
i got
i'm taking this volcano
[Music]